[Music]
magical and wonderful
until it's not I'm not happy
what tell me what's wrong I'm going this
is the person that I met three years ago
that guy was romantic romantic you're
pissing in front of me I'm staying
hydrated you should be happy for me I'm
a vegetarian state fish and pepperoni on
pizza cuz that doesn't count
mr. orpington eternia dog he's a lawyer
Wow clucks Neil can we tell anyone to be
happy games are you follow down I didn't
say that I heard you I didn't mean it
this is so hard it doesn't have to be I
just won't be happy no it's not called
gently refining in love it's for falling
in love because yeah it could hurt place
you're never gonna know unless you jump
off the ledge sure you are so worried
about everybody else that you don't give
a [ __ ] about the one person that's most
matter most well that's so nice Sam but
was the last time a cabbie gave you a
[ __ ] do they know we're driver kill
that's not funny I'm not laughing it is
kind of funny
thank you laughing Wow so he's kind of
lazy and let me go
stop punishing yourself what's something
simpler many Molly and I are just too
different like I see the glass of water
is half-full she sees the water as
poison
we don't understand how much pressure
there is from me it was easy for you I
don't want to have a baby when I'm low
man who can't pick up his [ __ ] - I
could think of nothing you would love
more than not having to carry your baby
yeah that would be nice
[Music]
[Music]